Do you ever hear a noise, not a bump in the
night but a hum, a mysterious, constant and
very low frequency noise?
If so, you may be one of an estimated 2% of
the global population that can hear “The
Hum”.
The Hum is the name given to an ominous and
very mysterious deep-rumbling noise that can
reportedly be heard by thousands of individuals
across the globe.
It apparently sounds like a very low-pitched
rumbling sound, kind of like a diesel-engine
truck idling in the distance.
But no matter how hard people search no one
has been able to locate the source of the
sound, it sounds like it’s coming from all
directions equally.
Some even say it comes from the sky.
This is a recording of The Hum made in Taos,
New Mexico.
For some The Hum causes headaches and nosebleeds.
It drives others completely insane, with at
least one suicide being attributed to The
Hum.
It’s usually heard in specific towns around
the globe for several months or years before
it disappears and for some people it never
goes away.
The first documented occurrence of the Hum
was in Bristol in the UK, in the 1970s.
A local newspaper asked Bristol city residents
“Have you heard the Hum?”
and over 800 people said they had.
Since then residents from hundreds of towns
and cities from all over the world have reported
hearing the Hum and always describe the sound
in a similar manner.
Some of the more notable locations, where
up to 12% of the population have heard the
noise, are Taos - New Mexico, Largs – Scotland
and Auckland – New Zealand.
Reports of the Hum have become so great that
a website has been created where people can
report their experience with The Hum and you
can view a map of all the reported cases.
The Hum has even been linked to terrorism.
In 2013 Aaron Alexis shot and killed twelve
innocent people at the Washington DC Navy
Yard.
Police later found the following message on
his computer “Ultra low frequency attack
is what I’ve been subject to for the last
three months.
And to be perfectly honest, that is what has
driven me to this.”
This and other evidence led conspiracy theorists
to conclude that the Hum is a government attack
or experiment being used on citizens to alter
their state of mind.
They believe the government generates the
Hum using satellites.
Other’s say the HAARP project in Alaska
is to blame.
But Illuminati and Lizard Men aside, has science
been able to find a reason for the Hum?
What is the cause?
Have animals learnt how to hum and are playing
a gigantic practical joke on us puny humans.
Is God bored?
Or is it just tinnitus?
The Hum is most commonly heard by people aged
between 55 and 70, so one instantly thinks
it’s the medical condition tinnitus, you
know how your granny is always complaining
about a ringing noise that isn’t actually
there?
Except for that one time you turned her hearing
aid to maximum, that was pretty bad.
But if the cause was tinnitus shouldn’t
the spread of people who’ve reported hearing
the Hum be evenly distributed across the globe?
After all, tinnitus doesn’t favour certain
regions.
But the Hum is usually reported by clusters
of people around specific locations.
Also, new research carried out recently in
Cambridge, England suggests that the source
of the Hum is external not internal, which
is what Hum sufferers have always argued.
People have also blamed the following things
for causing the Hum: Traffic, local factories
and heavy machinery, leaking pipes, phone
masts, wind farms, submarine communication
systems, UFOs and even mating fish – hundreds
of Southampton residents who could hear the
Hum were told it was being caused by a school
of mating Midshipman fish who make this eerie
sound, to try to attract a female.
Okay that single incident with the horny fish
could have been a genuine cause of the Hum,
but the other potential causes have mostly
been disproven.
However new research has suggested that microseismic
activity from ocean waves impacting the sea
bed causes our planet itself to vibrate in
certain areas around the globe, causing a
low-frequency droning sound.
Researchers say that this sound is such a
low frequency that only a small percentage
of the population would be able to hear it.
This ocean-based answer also explains why
the Hum is more commonly heard in costal towns.
So for some this answer has finally settled
their life-long quest to locate the source
of their annoying, ear-penetrating friend.
But for other Hum sufferers who disbelieve
this explanation, their search continues.
Thanks for watching.